قلت الاداره العسكريه في خاركيف هنا خمسه
عشره غاره روسيه استهدفت مدينه خاركيف
ومحيطها ومن جهته قلع عمده المدينه الى
الغارات استهدفت منشات للطاقه في خاركيف
ما تسبب في انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن
عدد من احياء المدينه
ومن جهتها قالت الاداره العسكريه في
اوديسا ان قصف صاروخيا روسيا استهدف
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في المدينه وافادت
الاداره العسكريه في كييف ان الدفاعات
الجويه تتصدى لاهداف جويه في سماء العاصمه
هذا وافادت الاداره العسكريه في كييف ان
الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لاهداف جويه روسيه
وبدوره قال عمده العاصمه الاوكرانيه الى
40% من سكان المدينه اصبحوا دون تدفئه
بسبب الهجوم الصاروخيه الاخير وقالت
الاداره الاقليميه في كييف ان الهجوم
الروسي استهدف منشاه للبنيه التحتيه واسفر
عن اصابه شخصين